Okay. So today we have two specific races
that I'm going to talk about for 2020, where
we really have extraordinarily uh, um, uh,
uh, inspiring. I guess I would call them opportunities
to take down some of the most prominent and
toxic Republicans in the Senate. Yesterday
I told you that Senate majority leader Mitch
McConnell has a challenger after, uh, later
on in the show. I'll talk to you a little
bit more about that race. But first today,
totally terribly toxic Trump tool. How about
that? Lindsey Graham has an opponent and the
opponent has raised a record breaking amount
of money.
His name is Jamie Harrison. He has raised
one point $5 million to challenge Lindsey
Graham in South Carolina for his Senate seat,
and if you haven't been paying attention to
Lindsey, he has become even more unhinged
under Donald Trump on leasing one of unleashing,
rather one of the most cartoonish and embarrassing
tirades that may be I've ever seen during
the confirmation hearing of Supreme Court
justice. Brett Kavanaugh. Remember when this
went down? If you wanted a FBI investigation,
you could come to us. What you want to do
is destroy this guy's life, hold this seat
open and hope you win in 2020 you said that
not me. You've got nothing to apologize for.
When you see Sotomayer and Kagan tell him
that Lindsey said, oh, because I voted for
them. I would never do to them. What you've
done to this guy, this system, most unethical,
sham, since I've been in politics, that was
real life.
That was not part of some poorly scripted
political drama or reality show and a a full
reality show. It would be really great to
remove Lindsay Graham and Jamie Harrison conceivably
could make that happen. Now let's, I always
am realistic with you in these races. I don't
do the thing where I pretend that someone
pulling 1% really has a shot at winning in
the presidential primary, and I'm not going
to be, you hear either Jamie Harrison is way
behind. He's raised one point $5 million,
but Lindsey Graham has nearly $5 million or
had $5 million in the bank at the end of the
first quarter of the year and they're still
calculating their second quarter total. So
he may have three, four, three or four times
as much money as Jamie Harrison and money
matters in our political system, as you know.
But this is one of the strongest candidates
in recent history to really have a shot at
taking out such a prominent Republican.
Senator Baito had a shot with Ted Cruz in
Texas, ultimately didn't happen. Jamie Harrison
is admittedly like many of these southern
Democrats, um, basically a centrist establishment
guy. But given the circumstances, that's okay
because we'd be much better off with Jamie
Harrison than with Lindsay Graham, particularly
in a state like South Carolina. Jamie Harrison
is a top official for the Democratic National
Committee. He's former chairman of the South
Carolina Democratic Party. He's an establishment
guy. I mean, there's no doubt about it, but
Lindsey Graham is just terrible and the polls
are pointing to an uphill battle. Graham has
a big lead in the polls as of right now. But
okay, we still have a while. Let's see what
we can do. And as I said before, uh, yesterday
talking about the Mitch McConnell Challenger
in Kentucky, the key is that even if Jamie
Harrison doesn't defeat Lindsey Graham in
the end, even if Amy McGrath doesn't ultimately
take out Mitch McConnell in 2020 getting the
Republican party to have to spend a bunch
of money defending incumbents in red states,
makes it more difficult for them to win other
seats because of limited money that they obviously
have.
And that's a very good thing. And people have
been writing to me about Lindsay Graham saying,
even though it goes against our principles
on the left, shouldn't the left be targeting
Lindsey Graham for being gay because Republicans
don't like it and they might vote them out.
I totally disagree with that. Strategy number
one, it's below us to stoop to that level.
Okay. We don't think there's anything wrong
with being gay, so why would we target another
candidate? Because they are, I don't know
if Lindsey, I don't know what took to what
level of, uh, uh, how publicly Lindsey Graham
is gay. Um, but I don't think it's a good
idea for Democrats to be doing this because
it's just the wrong thing to do. And there's
nothing wrong with being gay. But more importantly,
I also don't think it would work. The right
claims to be about family values.
But when it comes down to it, they voted for
Trump who was accused 15 times or more of
sexual assault. The mistresses, the entire
thing, they don't actually care. They're not
going to vote for a Democrat, most of them
anyway. And in the same way. Yeah, the anti
gay religious right in South Carolina, I get
it, but they don't actually care if the alternative
to Lindsay Graham is voting for a Democrat
because this is sport to them. They see this
as wins and losses, losses, period. It's below
us and it's wrong to start using Lindsey Graham's
sexual orientation against him. And by the
way, it also wouldn't be useful. Uh, so that's
what's going on with Lindsey Graham a little
bit later on in the program. I want to update
you about what's going on in Amy McGrath's
challenge of Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell in Kentucky. The fundraising
numbers are stunning for Amy McGrath, but
that's coming up a little bit later. Make
sure that you are following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show. Follow me on Instagram
at David Dot. Pacman. I recently posted a
behind the scenes shot of what the studio
here looks like, what I'm looking at while
I'm taping the show.
Follow me at David Dot. Pacman on Instagram.
See that and much, much more quick break as
they always are. And back right after
the